bonjour alexis ravi de vous retrouver
dans la médecine lrt france alors encore
un week-end politique de frais campagne
chargé avec la rentrée du modem dans le
morbihan une question existentielle pour
le parti de françois bayrou être ou ne
pas être intégrée dans la république en
marche oui c'était vraiment ça une mise
en scène un certain parlait même de
fiançailles pour que la république en
marche le parti créé par neil mac rond
pour accéder au pouvoir qu'il avait
donné ses initiales face une maison
commune avec le modem qui était lui le
bébé de françois bayrou à l'époque alors
il ya les pour et les contre 1 françois
bayrou essaye de te dire que ce serait
bien effectivement de clarifier pour les
français même s'il n'y avait pas
beaucoup de militants dans le morbihan
mais on voit bien que c'est une histoire
d'appareils avec en embuscade
edouard philippe et son nouveau parti
qui pourrait finalement est bien dégagée
françois bayrou qui avait été faisons
derouard en 2017 mais qui pourrait être
totalement anachronique en 2022 donc
françois bayrou essaye de se raccrocher
aux branches et en disant moi si je fais
cet accord là c'est pour assurer des
postes à des futurs députés modem qui
aurait l'éthique est en marche mais qu
on ne se tire pas dans les pattes entre
ceux qui viendraient du côté de manuel
valls eux qui viendrait du côté
d'edouard philippe édition de vos
parties et puis les sortants ceux de la
république en marche qui eux comptent
bien aussi être
réélu donc on est en train déjà de faire
des jeux d'appareils pour préparer les
législatives n'est même pas question là
des présidentielles alors alexis arnaud
montebourg lui était de retour à
frangy-en-bresse une fête de la rose
façon nostalgique une remise en scène
bourret est de retour sur ses terres il
sent l'odeur de la rose c'est un peu la
nostalgie et puis il y à une nouvelle
élection alors ils arrêtent de faire du
miel et le voilà de nouveau candidat il
est en train d'organiser ses équipes
avec des anciens de bercy la houle a été
ministre pendant quelque temps il fait
campagne aussi dans les ter à la
rencontre des français et puis là à
frangy en bresse il a voulu faire appel
au peuple de gauche en disant qu'il
avait des choses à faire mais on a
l'impression que toute la logique
d'arnaud montebourg finalement c'est
d'essayer de faire du mélenchon en soft
de dire que jean luc mélenchon est trop
extrême qu'il n'y arrivera pas mais que
lui oui avec une question à laquelle il
ne répond pas en disant il faut
finalement que l'europe nous laisse
tranquille et faire de la politique avec
le sourire je crois qu'il n'a pas lu les
traités européens arnaud montebourg est
peut-être falloir nous expliquer que
c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne
donc voilà c'est beaucoup de blabla une
mise en scène comme il aime le faire je
sais pas où ça ira mais clairement il
est là pour mettre des bâtons dans les
roues d'une candidature de jean luc
mélenchon et pour les alertes ce
week-end ça y est c'est tranché ce sera
donc un congrès mais pas avant décembre
donc une route de campagne qui s'ouvre
maintenant entre candidats du même bord
finalement oui c'est compliqué pour eux
les républicains y avait dans les
statuts du parti cette primaire et il
arrive à l'évacuer en faisant un congrès
alors ils sont quelques dizaines de
milliers à avoir voté pour cette
solution du congrès qui ne satisfait pas
tout le monde ça veut dire que vous
allez avoir peut-être aviez bertrand qui
va demandé l'absolution de ce congrès
c'est en décembre cédant longtemps il va
falloir départager c'est pas une
primaire ouverte donc là on est en train
de voir l air ce record n'est enfin se
recroqueviller sur lui-même avec d'un
côté la tacc d'eric zemmour 1 qui était
invitée lors des journées des
conservateurs disant que ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça et que le
prochain qui sortira de la primaire
élèves sera le premier ministe de
maquereau en gros du côté de chez l'air
on en veut à eric zemmour qu'il ne
devrais pas dire ça avec christian jacob
qui défend eric zemmour 1 donc on voit
bien que la droite traditionnelle est
tiraillé entre avoir des alliés du
centre et les faire venir dans une
première ouverte et puis essayer de ne
pas être tiré trop à droite par eric
zemmour avec 7 ce congrès qui va arriver
en décembre on a l'impression que ils
sont sûr là encore une logique fermé
aux attentes des français loin
finalement de la campagne présidentielle
qui s'ouvre et je pense que ça ne sert
pas les candidats actuellement de cette
primaire de ce congrès merci beaucoup
alexis l'édito politique d'alexis poule
en aide à retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux et